you write that my big problem with
social justice fundamentalism isn't the
ideology itself it's what it's Scholars
and activists started to do sometimes
around 2013 when they began to wield a
Kajol that's not supposed to have any
place in the country like the US so it's
the actions not the ideas well
implementation clear I don't like the
ideology I think it's a low rung
ideology I think it's morally
inconsistent based on you know it's
flip-flops on on its morals depending on
the the group I think it's Echo chambery
I think it's um I I think it's it's it's
full of inaccuracies and kind of can't
stand up to debate so I think it's a lot
but but there's a ton of low-ring
ideologies I don't like I don't like a
lot of religious doctrines I don't like
a lot of political doctrines right
the U.S is a place inherently that is a
mishmash of a ton of ideologies and I'm
not gonna like two-thirds of them at any
given time so my problem the reason I'm
writing about this is not because I'm
like by the way this ideology is not
something I like that's not interesting
the reason that it must be written about
right now this particular ideology is
because
it's not playing nicely with others what
what I if you want to be a hardcore you
know Evangelical Christian go in the US
says Live and Let Live not only are you
allowed to to have an echo chamber of
some kind you're it's actively protected
here Live and Let Live they can do what
they want you do what you want now if
the Evangelical Christian started saying
by the way anyone who says anything that
conflicts with Evangelical Christianity
is going to be severely socially
punished and they have the cultural
power to do so which they don't in this
case they might like to but they don't
have the power but they're able to get
anyone fired who they want and they're
able to actually change the curriculum
in all these schools in class to to
suddenly not conflict with no more
evolution in the in the textbooks
because they don't want it now I would
write a book about why about Evangelical
Christianity because that's what every
liberal regardless of what you think of
the actual horizontal beliefs
doesn't matter what they believe when it
when they start violating Live and Let
Live
and shutting down other area other
segments of society and in kind of it's
almost like a you know not to you know
it's not the best analogy but like it's
like a a Neco chamber is like a benign
tumor and what you what you have to
watch out for is a tumor that starts to
metastasize starts to forcefully spread
and damage the tissue around it and
that's what this particular ideology has
been doing do you worry about it you
know as an existential threat
to to
liberalism in in the west in the United
States
is it a problem or is it
the biggest problem that's threatening
all of human civilization it's I I would
never I would not say it's the biggest
problem it it might be I wouldn't if
someone if it turns out in 50 years
someone says actually it was I wouldn't
be shocked
but I also I would I wouldn't bet on
that because there's a lot of problems
I'm a little sorry to interrupt it is
popular to say that kind of thing though
and it's less popular to say the same
thing about AI or nuclear weapons which
worries me that I'm more worried about
nuclear weapons even still than I am
about wokeism so I've gotten I've had
probably a thousand arguments about this
that's one nice thing about spending six
years procrastinating on getting a book
done is you end up test battle testing
your ideas a million times so I've heard
this one a lot right which is
there's kind of three groups of former
Obama voters one is super woke now yeah
another one is super anti-woke now and
the third is what you just said which is
sure Wellness is over the top right
they're not you're not woke but
I think that the Andy woke people are
totally lost their mind and it's just
not that big a deal right
now here's why I disagree with that
because
it's not it's not wokeness itself
it's that
a of radical
um political movement of which there
will always be a lot in the country
has managed to do something that a
radical movement is not supposed to be
able to do in the U.S
which is they've managed to
hijack
institutions all across the country and
medical journals and universities and
you know the ACLU you know saying all
the you know activist organizations and
non-profits and and certain ngos yeah
and many and many tech companies and
what so it's not I think this thing is
so bad it's a little like we said with
Trump it's that what I'm what's the
reason Trump scares me is not because
Trump's so bad it's that because it
shows it's it reveals that we were
vulnerable to a demagogue candidate and
what wokeness reveals to me is that we
are currently and until something
changes will continue to be vulnerable
to a
um
a bully a bully movement and a
forcefully expansionist movement that
wants to actually
um
destroy the workings inner their liberal
gears and tear them apart and so so
here's the way I view a liberal
democracy is it is that it is is a bunch
of these institutions that were that
were trial and error crafted over you
know hundreds of years
and they all rely on trust public trust
and there's certain kind of feeling of
unity that that actually is critical to
a liberal democracy's functioning and
with I see this thing is as a parasite
on that that whose goal is and I'm not
saying by the way each individual in
this is I don't think they're bad people
I think that it's it's the ideology
itself has the property of its goal is
to tear apart the pretty delicate
workings of the liberal democracy and
Shred the critical lines of trust
and so you talk about Ai and you talk
about all these other big problems
nuclear right the reason I I like
writing about that stuff a lot more than
I like writing about politics this was a
fun topic for me is because I realized
that like all of those things if they're
gonna have a good future with those
things and they're actually threats like
I said we need to have a wits about us
and we need the the liberal you know
gears and and levers working we need the
liberal machine working and so if
something's threatening to undermine
that it affects everything else
we need to have our scientific mind
about us about these foundational ideas
but I I guess my sense of hope comes
from observing the immune system respond
to wokism
there seems to be a pro-liberalism
immune system
and not only that so like there's
intellectuals there's people that are
willing to do the fight you talk about
courage are being courageous and there
is a hunger for that such that those
ideas can become viral and they take
over so I just don't see a mechanism by
which wokism
accelerates like exponentially and takes
over like is expand it feels like as it
expands the immune system responds uh of
the the the immune system of the of
liberalism of of basically a country in
at least the United States that's still
ultimately at the core of the individual
values the freedom of speech Just
freedoms in general the freedom of an
individual but that's the battle
so to me it is like a virus and an
immune system yeah and
I totally agree I see the same story
happening and I you know I'm sitting
here rooting for the immune system oh
you're still worried well here's the
thing so a liberal democracy is in
always going to be vulnerable to a
movement like this right and there will
be more because it's not a totalitarian
dictatorship because if you can socially
pressure people to not say what they're
thinking you can suddenly start to just
take over right you can break the
liberalism of the liberal democracy
quite easily and suddenly a lot of
things are illiberal
on the other hand
the same vulnerability the same system
that's vulnerable to that also is hard
to truly conquer
because now the maoists
right similar kind of vibe they were
saying that science is evil and as a you
know and that their the intellectuals
are you know it's all it's all this big
conspiracy
but they could murder you
and they had the hard cudgel in their
hand right and the hard cudgel
is scary and
um and and you can conquer a country
with the hard cudgel but you can't use
that in the U.S so what they have is a
soft cudgel which can have the same
effect
initially you can scare people into
shutting up you can't maybe imprison
them and murder them but if you can
socially ostracize them and get them
fired that basically is going to have
the same effect so the soft cudgel can
have the same effect for a while but the
thing is
it's it's a little bit of a house of
cards because it relies on fear and as
soon as
that fear goes away
the whole thing falls apart right the
soft cultural requires people to be so
scared of getting canceled or getting
whatever and as soon as some people
start you know Toby lutka of Shopify I
always like think about you know he just
said you know what I'm not scared of
this soft cudgel and spoke up
and said we're not political at this
company and we're not a family we're a
team and we're going to do this and you
know what like they're thriving you will
be on this podcast his seems like a
fascinating human he's amazing he spoke
up he's one of the smartest and like
kindest dudes but he's also
um he has courage at a time when it's
hard but here's the thing is that it's
different than that you need so much
less courage against a soft cudgel than
you do the Iranians throwing their
hijabs Into the Fire those people's
courage just just blows away any courage
we have here because they might get
executed
that's the thing is that you can
actually have courage right now and it's
so
don't worry about it
um
oh man the irony of that and you talk
about so two things to fight this
there's two things awareness and courage
what's the awareness piece
the awareness piece is
um
is is under first just no understanding
the stakes
like getting our heads out of the sand
and being like technology is blowing up
exponentially where our society's trust
is devolving like we're kind of falling
apart in some important ways we're
losing our grip on some stability at the
worst time
that's the first point just the big
picture and then also awareness of I
think this vertical axis or whatever
your version of it is this concept of
how do I really form my beliefs where do
they actually come from where you know
did they are they someone else's beliefs
am I following a checklist
um how about my values you know I used
to identify with the blue party or the
red party but now they've changed and
and I suddenly am okay with that is that
because my values changed with it or am
I actually anchored to the party not to
any principle asking yourself these
questions
um asking your you know looking for
where do I feel disgusted by fellow
human beings you know that maybe I'm I'm
being a crazy tribal person without
realizing it how about the people around
me am I being bullied by some Echo
chamber without realizing it
um am I the bully somewhere right so
that's the first just just I think just
to kind of do a self-audit and and and
um and I think that like just just some
awareness like that it's just a
self-audit about these things can can go
a long way but if you don't if you keep
it to yourself it's almost useless
because if it doesn't if you don't have
without you know awareness without
courage does very little so courage is
when you take that awareness and you
actually export it out into the world
and it starts affecting other people and
so courage can happen on multiple levels
it can happen by first of all just stop
saying stuff you don't believe if you're
being pressured by a kind of a ideology
or a movement to say stuff that you
don't actually believe just stop just
just just stay in your ground and don't
say anything that's that's courage
that's one first step
start speaking out in small groups
starts you know actually speaking around
see what happens the sky doesn't usually
fall actually people usually respect you
for it like you know and it's not not
every group but like you'd be surprised
and then eventually you know maybe start
speaking out in bigger groups start
going public you know Global go public
with it but and you don't need everyone
doing this look some people will lose
their jobs for it I'm not talking to
those people most people won't lose
their jobs but they have the same fear
as if they would right and it's like
what are you gonna get criticized or are
you gonna get a bunch of people you know
angry Twitter people will will criticize
you like it yeah it's not pleasant but
actually that's a little bit like our
primitive Minds fear that really
back when it was programmed that kind of
ostracism or criticism will get leave
you out of the tribe and you'll die
today it's kind of a delusional fear
it's not actually that scary and the
people who have realized that can
exercise incredible leadership right now